I can evolve it I get candy for it here
we're gonna take stole candies yeah high
roof
so on the same an eco channel where we
are trying to increase the production
value of the show so I want to you know
so Carmichael's like wait a minute why
aren't we using more phantoms it's
pretty much because I don't know how to
apply them today Carmichael gets pilot
lessons and you guys do too much danger
zone words they are sanding the ceiling
to our studio right now some place is a
dusty mess so I'm going to try to hold
my breath all the way from opening the
door to getting into the camera
Hey
all right
maybe not
even though my vacation in Iceland was
incredible there was something that was
really bugging me which was the fact
that the form to printer arrived
I think to propose a question what if
you could make it do anything you wanted
to do let's go
looks like we have resin trays here okay
here we go form two Quick Start Guide
more trays I love it a build platform
box unlabeled now for good stuff Wow
okay so this is sweet to get this thing
operational need to take our resin trays
or resin tanks won't take our actual
resin which is here fill with the resin
tanks put them into the printer read the
QuickStart guide to figure out how this
thing works I think more importantly we
need a place to put this this is all the
materials we need to get started here
and the next step is popping each one
open and following the instructions very
carefully so we don't screw anything a
couple safety things to know when you're
going to fly a drone don't fly a drone
over people because drones at some point
will drop out of the air so if you are
over people that means you are dropping
a giant piece of machinery onto people's
heads don't fly it over people unless
the trained professionals then it's okay
to drop it on them well no but they at
least they know the risks second safety
thing look at your power lines take a
moment and have your situational
awareness so you have to make a mental
map of where it is clear to fly last
lesson don't fly your battery to lower
than 30% voltage or charge when your
battery gets to 30% you land so the
biggest challenge to flying a drone is
that when you turn and when you move
it's all relative to the drones
direction the drone is facing away from
us and I push left on a control stick
the drone goes left but if the drone is
now facing us they won't go
left relative to you so right now the
drone is warming up that can be as many
satellites as it can see and once it
connects to at least six it's going to
set the home point we're going in yellow
yeah eventually they go green green
green green and that's a sign that's
found its home point it is ready to fly
you'll push the thumbsticks into the
inside corners the outside corners both
of them work
all right so now the drug is on and
ready to fly choose how you turn it off
hold down on the throttle and now it's
off let's see you take out
doing it alright five bar is a little
bit in a world of infinite possibilities
the thing I choose to do is make
Dungeons & Dragons miniatures I know
it's pretty terrible but honestly it's a
great place to start because basically
I'll be able to understand just exactly
like what level detail we're working at
and all that stuff at a printer this is
connected through each nets any single
person on the network here can just log
right in and print anything name I'm now
logged in to pretty koala it
automatically generates those supports
so that this thing now has something
holding it up yeah so the screen will
show you a little model the pin you're
gonna make right send its printer
alright see what happens what makes this
printer special most printers use a
spool of plastic that heats it up and
just kind of makes layers and layers and
layers and layers this printer works
much differently this uses a pool of
plastic to make layers it will feed
liquid into this tray and there's going
to be a little laser underneath it that
shoots lasers into the liquid hardening
it piece by piece this allows it to
create 3d prints with laser accuracy all
right congrats you've learned to hover
you go left a little bit go right a
little bit
forwards a little bit backwards a little
bit get a feel your challenge is to not
crash ever so you don't push yourself
beyond your comfort zone safely expand
your comfort zone it's like a car you
don't crash your car every couple weeks
cuz you're driving so hard you just
don't crash
you nervous yeah
okay backward up a bit
basically this is a little boat smallest
this detail goes is point zero to five
millimeters it is really really really
intense and detailed small I got one
piece in there another piece alright so
these guys are done taking a bath their
work
tiny tiny minuscule small errors but
that's mostly because I took a model
that was supposed to be made much larger
and made it a fraction of the size that
being said if you look closely you can
see an incredible amount of detail on
here you can even see a little lines of
the wood slats that are supposed to be
lining the deck a little escape raft on
there is perfectly modeled I'm pretty
impressed
I wanted a super high detail high that
crazy
that's incredible detail it's so tiny
it's meant to be printed out like this
big I heard you like small boats so I
put another small boats on your small
boat what oh wow we did a little test to
just kind of show off the capabilities
here I printed out the same model on the
MakerBot and the same model on the forum
ii think the difference speaks for
itself
one's a little crystal Knight and one's
a little play-doh dude you know there's
different types of tools obviously this
does higher detail so it's better for
smaller objects but MakerBot still does
a really good job at quickly making
larger objects using less material and
cheaper materials it's kind of a
trade-off that being said that's sweet
it's awesome
so far so good
Oh Michael I want you to bring drones
over here
give it up
there you go perfect it's working can
you go change my underwear
Dave plus you didn't crash everybody who
doesn't crash missin a plus and if you
crash it straight up
Seifer crash how do you get an F you
kill somebody tell her to have next time
Carmichael flies with a camera on the
drone